well brian las vegas wants to fast
forward
that is the message of a new ad campaign
that hopes to catch convention
organizers attention
and bring them back christian casadas
joining us now live from our newsroom
with some of the shows that are making
their comeback plans kristen well denise
it's another sign that las vegas is
coming
back to life and why not do it in style
we have a brand new facility with the
convention center right next door
which is available now here are some of
the conventions from
2019 that left a mark in size
right here in las vegas top spot with
ces with about 175
000 attendees that is followed by sema
with 160 thousand
nab reported 93 000 the magic
marketplace convention will be back in
the spring
and fall plus amazon's web services
makes up
the top five biggest shows others like
the venetian shot show
world of concrete and the national
association of home builders
also brought in more than 60 thousand
participants
the new 15 second spot from the lbcva
highlights a sample
of what las vegas has to offer post
[Music]
pandemic
[Music]
music is pretty catchy there right well
the ad promises the return
of live meetings and events with
enhanced health and wellness protocols
more than 2 million square feet of new
and innovative meeting space
groundbreaking transportation services
new resorts
obviously the list goes on and on now
the calendar
is filling up ces will return in person
in january sema and nab
are also set for this fall the magic
marketplace
are booked for february and in august at
the mandalay bay
so our city will definitely be very busy
and las vegas obviously is ready so we
have a complete list for you to check
out
on our website right now
eightnewsnow.com christian casadas 8
news now